how does a Goldman Sachs alum with three
decades and finance and zero experience
in the public sector end up with their
signature printed on American money and
confirmed by the Senate because of one
trump card loyalty to Donald Trump
Stephen venetians path to the 77
secretary of the Treasury of the United
States happened because he was in the
right place at the right time this is
the story of how Stephen minuchin saw
the deal of a lifetime
and took a gamble on Trump to become the
most important financial figure in
America if you were to write a novel
about a privileged young man setting out
on a privileged course of privilege you
were right about Stephen Merchant
that's max Abelson I'm a reporter of
Bloomberg News max file minuchin for
weeks for a Bloomberg business cover
story with zack mutter i'm a reporter on
the finance team here at bloomberg to
track magicians paths from Wall Street
to Hollywood to bank ownership to
politics first some background Steven
venusian is the son of Robert minutia a
former partner at Goldman Sachs for
three decades it was so respected that
his nickname at the investment bank was
coach Steven venusian attended Yale in
1981 where he was a member of the Skull
and Bones secret society and drove a
Porsche in New Haven where he was
publisher of the Yale Daily News
Steven Newton was ceaseless in his
attempts to get across to us that he was
the youngest ever publisher he kept
emphasizing that the publishers are
normally juniors but he did it as a
sophomore after graduating in 1985 he
took an internship at the investment
bank Salomon Brothers when his
internship ended his career at goldman
sachs began in 2002 after 17 years at
goldman minuchin left to work at a hedge
fund owned by the liberal billionaire an
enemy of the right George Soros he
wanted to start his own fund and he
started it under the auspices of Soros
and then later he kind of went off on
his own gave it its own name called a
dune capital but the funding was still
from Soros venusian then branched out
into the arts in 2006 he got it to
Hollywood buying a DreamWorks film
library and partnership with Soros and
he financed movies one of which was
avatar
the highest-grossing picture of all time
his next career move while making
minutia extremely wealthy has been a
lightning rod of controversy he said
that in the summer of 2008 he was
watching news footage of people lined up
around the block of a bank that was then
called IndyMac he said out loud I've
seen this game before this bank is gonna
fail we need to buy it
a group of goldman sachs partners led by
stephen minuchin cobbled together 1.6
billion dollars to kind of recapitalize
this smoking crater of a bank venusian
changed the name of the bank from
IndyMac to one west and like within a
year it was just stunningly profitable
and it was profitable at the same time
some critics started calling it up
foreclosure they foreclosed on something
like 36,000 homeowners during that six
year period when they went to sell the
bank last year there was a public
hearing and borrower after borrower
stood up and and talk to the police
gave these horrible stories according to
bloomberg calculations after manoosh in
sold one west for 3.4 billion dollars in
2015
manoosh in' may have personally pocketed
more than three hundred eighty million
dollars from the sale when Trump talked
to people about minuchin what he was so
impressed by was the amount of money
he'd made on that deal after IndyMac and
Hollywood manoosh ins turned to politics
came from a chance encounter with Donald
Trump at a Republican primary victory
party in New York he wasn't planning on
being on stage with Trump but then he
sort of ends up bumping into Trump
beforehand going in stayed with him and
the next stage from Basques him to help
him on the campaign and he asked minutia
and start fundraising for the first time
and so it's gonna be a six-month
investment of time that could pay off
big-time
said to Zack and I no one's gonna be
asking why I'm doing this if I'm in the
administration a minutia n-- was right
the payoff was huge when Trump won the
election minutiae was rewarded for his
loyalty during the campaign with the
Treasury roll but like Trump
manoosh ins views on economic policy are
shrouded in mystery
so while there isn't a whole lot to go
on and seeing how minutia will navigate
political waters he fits in perfectly
with the Trump cabinet that is low on
experience but high on loyalty
[Music]